[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedriger
ihnen allen einen schönen guten abend
verbringen sie in den nächsten 20
minuten wieder auf den stand der dinge
natürlich auch sportlich wieder mit
kristin otto flott gebündelt guten abend
dann schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
wichtigsten ereignisse im überblick
später dank für afghanistan einsatz die
bundesregierung würde ich die
soldatinnen und soldaten mit einem
großen zapfenstreich
steigende energiepreise wie können
verbraucher entlastet werden die eu
kommission sucht nach lösungen
und eine star trek legende hebt ab
captain kirk darsteller william shatner
fliegt mit 90 jahren ins all
[Musik]
die afghanistan rückkehrer der
bundeswehr werden in diesen minuten mit
einem großen zapfenstreich geehrt und
sie wissen auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr waren und bleibt ein
sensibles thema was vor allem historisch
begründet ist auch darum war man in
dieser frage lange sehr zurückhaltend
bis zu diesem einen ereignis die
terroranschläge vom 11 september 2001
sie haben ja alles verändert der
bundestag beschloss danach mit großer
mehrheit sich am militäreinsatz der usa
und der nato zu beteiligen es folgten
dann 20 jahre einsatz in afghanistan
insgesamt haben dort über 90.000
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten ihren
einsatz geleistet
59 kamen dabei ums leben über die
würdigung ihres einsatzes heute in
berlin berichtet ines trams
kranzniederlegung am ehrenmal der
bundeswehr
bundespräsident bundestagspräsident und
die verteidigungsministerin gedenken der
soldaten die in afghanistan einsatz ums
leben kamen
zeitgleich bereitet sich matthias thiele
auf den tag vorgeladen ist er zum
abschluss appell als soldat wurde er in
kundus mehrfach mit raketen beschossen
die psychischen folgen quälen ihn bis
heute seit die taliban wieder an der
macht sind hält er seinen einsatz für
umsonst
oft zu hause und denke über den sinn und
die
ernsthaftigkeit der sache nach was man
da eigentlich gemacht hat in seinem
leben eigentlich verheizt hat für nicht
für mich zu mittel nicht so genau
matthias jehle mit kameraden auf dem weg
zum abschluss appel sie finden viel zu
wenig sieht die deutsche gesellschaft
die die im einsatz sind heute nun soll
das anders sein große würdigung der
soldaten im verteidigungsministerium
sie stehen heute im mittelpunkt kein
einsatz zuvor hat die bundeswehr so sehr
geprägt wie dieser einsatz in
afghanistan
keiner zuvor war so lange so intensiv so
gefährlich er begann als einsatz zur
friedenssicherung doch wurde zum
kampfeinsatz schwerfiel gesellschaft und
politik das anzuerkennen im august der
fall von kabul gescheitert der versuch
einen demokratischen staat zu errichten
ein rückzug von der welt seit der noch
keine option so der bundespräsident
wir müssen uns der welt stellen so wie
sie ist
zugleich den anspruch bewahren sie nicht
so zu lassen
ich bin überzeugt
deutsche außen- und sicherheitspolitik
nach afghanistan muss ehrliche klüger
und stärker werden in diesen minuten
werden die soldatinnen und soldaten mit
einem großen zapfenstreich vor dem
reichstag gewürdigt heute ist der tag
der wertschätzung die aufarbeitung des
einsatzes ist aber längst noch nicht
abgeschlossen
gehen wir nach berlin zu chakuza
labbadia kultur die machtübernahme der
taliban in afghanistan war zuletzt eine
dimitri demütigung für die beteiligten
truppen und eine große schmach für die
verantwortliche politik was bedeutet
jetzt dieser zapfenstreich
also dieser zapfenstreich ist vor allem
mal eine besondere ein besonderer
ausdruck der wertschätzung denn anders
als sonst üblich bei dieser zeremonie
stehen heute tatsächlich nicht politiker
im mittelpunkt und auf dem podest
sondern soldatinnen und soldaten das
kann man wahrscheinlich auch als zeichen
von dem mut der politik
einschätzen
angesichts der fehler die auch passiert
sind in diesem einsatz und vor allem zum
ende des einsatzes mit dem abzug mit dem
völlig missglückten abzug der ja den
einsatz insgesamt infrage gestellt hat
und bei so vielen fragezeichen ist auch
klar ist kann nicht bei dieser geste
heute bleiben die erwartungen in der
truppe gehen darüber weit darüber hinaus
man will zum beispiel wissen wie geht es
weiter mit auslandseinsätzen der
bundeswehr
warum und unter welchen bedingungen
sollen soldatinnen und soldaten künftig
im ausland ihr leben riskieren dass es
eine aufgabe der künftigen
bundesregierung und des künftigen
parlamentes sich darüber zu verständigen
und da klare linien zu definieren für
eine bundeswehr die nach diesem
afghanistan einsatz nicht mehr dieselbe
ist wie vorher danke schack und dann
nach berlin und weitere infos über den
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan finden
sie in unserer zdf heute app so auch ein
ausführliches interview mit
brigadegeneral ian zahl der unter
anderem einblicke ins seelenleben
beteiligter soldatinnen und soldaten
gewehrt
die kalte jahreszeit steht vor der tür
und die wird teuer das spielt ja jeder
der zuletzt getankt oder auf die
heizkostenabrechnung geschaut hat die
erzeugerpreise steigen drastisch zeigen
auch aktuelle zahlen vom statistischen
bundesamt zum beispiel heizöl im august
lagen die preise hier um gut 64 prozent
höher als im vorjahresmonat und auch
beim erdgas ein deutliches plus von 44
prozent beim strom eine steigerung von
rund 20 prozent die probleme die
betreffen verbraucher in ganz europa
zeigt uns jetzt in einem beispiel gunnar
krüger und auch wie die eu darauf
reagieren will
josé luis haas ist rentner in barcelona
weil die energiekosten steigen hat er
ein problem
ich mache für euch mal das nicht an
ausnahmsweise
seine stromrechnung hat sich nämlich
zuletzt fast verdoppelt
25 euro mehr das gebe ich sonst in einer
woche im supermarkt aus soll ich um
strom zu bezahlen etwa
mehr einkaufen gehen ein fall von
energie armut und damit die nicht weiter
wächst erlaubt die eu kommission was
staaten wie spanien und frankreich zum
teil schon plane im werkzeugkasten gegen
den energiepreis schock liegen energie
checks für ärmere verbraucher
staatshilfen für unternehmen und weniger
steuern auf gas und strom
damit wollen wir zunächst europas
verbraucher schützen vor allem die
schwächsten zweitens müssen wir unser
energiesystem
widerstandsfähiger macht die kommission
denkt dabei an den ausbau der
erneuerbaren
mitgliedstaaten im süden denken weiter
an das gas europa müsse gemeinsam
einkaufen und bevorraten es geht jetzt
wirklich darum zu sagen wie kommen wir
so schnell wie möglich weg vom gas und
nicht wie schaffen wir neue
institutionen die gas einkaufen wollen
der gasversorger er und nimmt gerade
keine neukunden wegen der preissprünge
was zeigt auch deutsche verbraucher sind
betroffen die werkzeuge der eu
kommission will die bundesregierung
dabei bislang nicht nutzen
pflegerinnen und pfleger wissen es zu
pflegende und ihre angehörigen erst
recht es muss sich etwas ändern mehr
personal und zeit für die pflege darüber
berät seit heute auch der deutsche
pflegetag denn die zahl derer die pflege
brauchen die wächst rasend schnell
schauen sie mal schon jetzt sind wir bei
4 millionen pflegebedürftigen und in
zehn jahren könnten es fünf millionen
sein was kaum mit wächst das ist die
zahl der pflegekräfte im moment fehlen
200.000 von ihnen und bis 2030 könnten
es 500.000 zu wenig sein petra auto
berichtet aus ludwigsburg hat aber auch
was positives entdeckt
es war er immer so wichtig gut
geschminkt zu sein und schön zurecht
gemacht doch cornelia brunner kann das
nicht mehr allein seit neun jahren liegt
sie hier im kleeblatt pflegeheim
pattonville sogenannte wohlfühlangebote
die haben im bürokratischen pflegealltag
kaum platz
die brauchen das einfach die freuen sich
dann sei es nur so dann noch mal kurz
daneben setzt oder gerade sie dann so
schminkt mehr zeit für sowas schenkt
ihnen jetzt eine neue app sandra saat
sprich zum beispiel den blutzuckerwert
einfach im zimmer ins handy
198 vor dem mittagessen die information
trägt sich von alleine ins richtige
formular ein er hat mit seinem bruder
diese spracherkennungs app erfunden mein
opa kam ins pflegeheim und dabei ist uns
aufgefallen wie viel arbeit die
dokumentation doch ist wie viel zeit da
reingesteckt wird und so kamen wir auf
die idee den sprachassistenten zu
entwickeln sie arbeiten viel lohn
verdienen wenig sind oft unterbesetzt
und überbelastet an die neue regierung
alte forderungen es geht nicht nur ums
geld aber auch heute beim deutschen
pflegetag in berlin einer der ersten
elementaren schritte ist es die
vergütung von pflegefachpersonen in
allen versorgungsgebieten auf einen
grund niveau von 4000 euro anzuheben der
lohn bedeutet mehr lebensqualität
bedeutet höhere gesellschaftliche
wertschätzung und die chance
berufsrückkehrerinnen zu gewinnen hohe
erwartung im pflegebereich gibt es für
eine neue bundesregierung viel zu tun
schlechte nachrichten gibt es für
beschäftigte die wegen allgemeiner
schließungen im corona shutdown nicht
arbeiten konnten arbeitgeber sind nicht
verpflichtet ihnen für den ausfall
entgelt zu zahlen das hat das
bundesarbeitsgericht entschieden
begründung arbeitgeber tragen keine
verantwortung wenn der staat
flächendeckende schließungen anordnete
und besonders hart betrifft das mini
jobber denn kurzarbeitergeld gibt es für
sie nicht
seit den ampel sondierungen wird eine
alte frage neu diskutiert es geht um die
legalisierung von cannabis
polizeigewerkschaften und einige
mediziner sehen dass nach wie vor
kritisch aber die beiden kanzler macher
parteien grüne und fdp sind für eine
freigabe und auch die spd kann sich dass
unter gewissen bedingungen vorstellen
anselm stern bringt ihnen die argumente
beider seiten noch einmal näher
ein dauerbrenner die frage nach der
legalisierung neuer nachschub für den
streit ums gas kommt jetzt von karl
lauterbach arzt und spd
gesundheitsexperte er hat seine meinung
geändert ist nun für den legalen
kontrollierten verkauf von cannabis an
erwachsene
cannabis wird heute sehr häufig auch auf
der straße abgegeben mit beimischungen
diese beimischungen haben das ziel den
konsumenten abhängiger zu machen und das
ist eine gefährdung nicht für gefährlich
hatte immer öfter würde sogar heroin
dazu gemischt das könne verhindert
werden wenn der handel nicht mehr in der
illegalen verborgenheit stattfindet
cannabis zum kaufen wie alkohol oder
zigaretten die polizeigewerkschaften
warnen davor deutlich wir glauben dass
wenn legalisiert werden würde der
eindruck entsteht es sei ungefährlich so
und dieser eindruck ist fatal fatal weil
das kiffen dem körper schwer zusetzen
können gerade bei jungen menschen meinen
einige experten
es geht hier ist der linie um psychosen
es geht um angst und depressive
störungen
entwicklungsstörungen und neue befunde
deuten darauf hin dass insbesondere die
hirnentwicklung bei pubertären
cannabiskonsum beeinträchtigt wird
gefahren betonen die einen die anderen
sagen cannabis könne helfen bei manchen
krankheiten und das verbot bringe ihm
nichts noch ist der verkauf eine
straftat in deutschland die debatte
darum ein dauerbrenner
ja bald ist es zwei jahre her dass sich
großbritannien und die eu nach zähen
verhandlungen auf ein brett abkommen
einigen konnten und jetzt droht london
damit wieder auszusteigen die eu will
nun vorschläge präsentieren um das
umstrittene nordirland protokoll zu
retten darin ist festgelegt dass es
keine grenzkontrollen zwischen
nordirland und dem eu-mitglied republik
irland mehr gibt notwendig werden
dadurch aber kontrollen des
schiffsverkehrs zwischen nordirland und
dem rest des königreiches yasin herr
lang
der laden läuft bei diesen
lebensmittelproduzenten im nordirischen
onepoint an der grenze zur republik
irland das unternehmen beliefert kaffee
aus ketten und supermärkte in beiden
teilen irlands in europa und dem
mittleren osten mit hochwertigem essen
zum mitnehmen
das geschäft expandiert und das trotz
der unwägbarkeiten die der dreck sind
besonders in nordirland mit sich
gebracht hat
über drei jahre mussten wir uns auf den
wechsel vorbereiten wir wussten nicht
was passieren würde jetzt haben wir ein
abkommen das erlaubt zutaten aus dem
süden irlands zu beziehen statt aus dem
vereinigten königreich und das wurde von
der britischen regierung auch so
unterschrieben
um bis zu 77 prozent ist der
warenaustausch mit den süden zuletzt
gestiegen der regierung in london
gefällt das gar nicht unter eu
handelsbedingungen läuft es in
nordirland prima im restlichen
königreich bei lieferproblemen für sprit
und andere waren jedoch weniger das
wirft kein gutes licht auf den text erst
gestern führte der britische chef
unterhändler wieder den streit ums
nordirland protokoll
mit dem protokoll hat die eu und
übervorteilt als uns die hände gebunden
waren es kann in seiner jetzigen form
nicht bestehen bleiben
bei all jenen die sich eine enge
anbindung ans königreich wünschen ist
das abkommen verhasst die meisten
nordiren jedoch sehen die vorteile
menschen wie unternehmer brian ried
möchten nichts weiter als in ruhe ihrem
geschäft nachgehen die frage ist ob die
politiker in london und belfast ihn
lassen
der weltraum unendliche weiten in die
drang william shatner oft vor als
captain kirk in star trek und auf
deutsch ist es damals raumschiff
enterprise aber heute ist der
schauspieler tatsächlich zum ersten mal
im all gewesen oder zumindest in sphären
über der erde an bord einer amazon
raumkapsel was für ein abenteuer das
sagen die shatner fans unnötig und
abgehoben sagen kritiker und die ganze
geschichte erzählt und zeigt tom palme
abflug in den texanischen himmel
richtung weltraum star trek liegende
william shatner ist mit an bord und mit
90 der älteste mann im all vor diesem
abenteuer war durchaus nervös
ich fühle mich wohl aber auch unwohl ich
werde sehr glücklich sein wenn wir
starten und wir haben den moment der
inspiration wenn wir in die weiten des
universums schauen
ebenfalls dabei zwei unternehmer und die
vize-präsidentin der raumfahrt firma
blue origin die amazon gründer jeff
bezos gehört anders als captain kirks
missionen durch die weiten des fernseh
universums endet der echte kurztrip in
100 kilometern höhe an der grenze zum
weltall und nach nur zehn minuten landet
die crew sicher in der texanischen wüste
ich bin so voller emotionen was da
passiert ist es ist so außergewöhnlich
und
während sich jeff bezos über den rummel
rund um seine weltraum firma freut
diskutieren andere die folgen für die
umwelt besser sagt er verwende für seine
raketen den umweltfreundlichsten
treibstoff der möglich ist flüssiger
wasserstoff und flüssiger sauerstoff
doch forscher warnen selbst das könne
die dünnere ozonschicht schädigen auch
wenn am ende nur wasserdampf ausgestoßen
werde
was hätte ludwigsburg wohl dazu gesagt
wir sind uns völlig sport und christel
jetzt geht wieder runter ab in die wüste
deutschlands beste tennis profis spielen
in indian wells weiter erfolgreich
zuerst zog angelique kerber ins
viertelfinale ein durch das 6 4 6 1
gegen die australierin ellie atom
janovic danach sicherte sich alexander
zverev das achtelfinale
alexander zverev hat einmal mehr starke
nerven bewiesen schon im ersten satz
liegt der durch ein frühes break des
briten andy murray mit 0 23 zurück aber
es wäre bleibt fokussiert kann das spiel
drehen und gewinn satz eins mit 6 zu
viel game im zweiten satz gerät wäre
wieder in rückstand doch die nerven
halten auch diesmal der deutsche
olympiasieger kämpft sich in den
tiebreak und dieser endet spektakulär
werder gewinnt damit zum ersten mal
gegen den grossen andy murray und steht
im achtelfinale gegen den franzosen geld
movies
im rassismus verfahren gegen dennis
erdmann vom drittliga verein erster fc
saarbrücken hat das dfb bundesgericht
das strafmaß reduziert von ursprünglich
acht auf sechs wochen wodurch der
abwehrspieler sofort wieder einsetzt
meist
sechs wochen sperre hat dennis erdmann
schon hinter sich die restlichen zwei
werden dem saarbrücker bis zum saison in
der auf bewährung ausgesetzt obwohl er
sie weiterhin bestreitet seine
rassistischen äußerungen im
drittligaspiel ende august gegen
magdeburg wurden nicht mehr angefochten
sondern nur noch das strafmass und damit
hatte sein anwalt erfolg wenn da
irgendwelche missverständnisse bahn hat
er auch verdeutlicht dass ich mir das
leid tut aber wir wollten einen
abschluss finden für ihn für den klub
und auch für die zeugen und alle anderen
beteiligten der rat des anwalts für
seinen mandanten und andere künftig
gefährdete ist so kurz wie treffend und
halten
die deutschen u 21 fußballer bleiben auf
kurs richtung em teilnahme gegen ungarn
wurde der vierte sieg in der
qualifikation verbucht zwei treffer beim
5 2 1-triumph im jet erzielte stürmer
kevin schade vom sc freiburg es läuft
also weisungs voll unter dem neuen
trainer antonio di salvo zwei spiele
zwei siege verbucht vielen dank
christian das war der sport und zum
schluss noch mal mit in die tiefe des
ozeans zu einem seltenen
naturschauspiels so selten dass ein
kamerateam fünf jahre täglich unter
wasser ging um den perfekten moment
einzufangen und hier ist er schon mal
sacken branche beim laichen das sieht so
aus ausgezeichnet als beste natur
fotografie des jahres preise gab es auch
für diesen unterwasser elefanten in
einem zoo in indien und diese haben in
kanada die sich zu küssen scheinen
schick schick vom glück beim
fotografieren zum glück hoffentlich bei
den zahlen die vom mittwochslotto und
die lauten 4 7 10 18 31 35 und die
zusatz superzahl tschuldigung fünf
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 557 ja
leider trübt sich das wetter von morgen
langsam ein aber es gibt die chance auf
sonne wo das erfahren sie gleich von
katja horneffer um 21.45 wie gewohnt das
heute journal mit claus kleber wir eben
heute team sind froh dass die leute
zugeschaut haben wünschen uns dass auch
für morgen um sieben bis dahin schön
dankeschön mittwochabend
[Musik]
guten abend gestern habe ich ihnen etwas
vom skandinavien führen erzählt und
heute möchte ich ihnen den mistral
vorstellen dieser kräftige nordwind der
durch das rhonetal bis weit aufs
mittelmeer hinaus bei uns in deutschland
ist der wind zur zeit eher gering das
ändert sich aber bis morgen abend dann
zeigt es vor allen dingen an der nordsee
heute nacht ziehen regenwolken von der
küste über die östlichen mittelgebirge
weiter nach niederbayern im westen ist
es dagegen trocken und zum teil auch
klar und an den alpen wird es kalt da
sinken die temperaturen auf +3 bis -2
grad und ich könnte es also sogar mal
hier und da für eisglätte reichen im
norden bald die nacht milder mit 12 bis
4 grad und morgen gibt es ein deutliches
nord west süd ost gefälle bei den
temperaturen in nordwesten wird es
relativ mild bei 15 bis 16 grad im
südosten werden dagegen zum teil kaum 10
grad erreicht und auch morgen über tag
fällt noch etwas regen hier im osten das
wird im laufe des tages immer weniger im
westen ist es deutlich freundlicher
besonders strahlend scheint die sonne am
oberrhein oder auch im schwarzwald am
freitag regnet es dann vor allen dingen
in norddeutschland kräftig danach gibt
es trübes wetter allerdings zeigt sich
auch häufiger die sonne und vor allen
dingen rund um aachen könnte es dann am
sonntag für bis zu 18 grad reichen guten
abend